it's door dash story let's go to the
door dash story here all right page
three
uh uncle tom is uh very excited today
which is fantastic all right
every door dash employee from engineers
to ceo will make deliveries this is a
cnn story doordash is asking its
employees all the way up the ranks to
its ceo to make a delivery at least once
a month some are not cheering the news
the on-demand food delivery company new
year will reinstate a program called we
dash that it has paused during the
pandemic as a company grew the founder
wanted everyone to experience different
parts of the product so we could get
closer to our audiences and understand
how the product works a doordash
employee comes back who's making four
hundred thousand dollars to complain
about a company-wide initiative
requiring that he personally make one
delivery a month this is an insider
story
doordash making engineers uh deliver
mandatory we dash starts next year we
need to dash once a month we will be
tracked in performance reviews
what the actual f
i didn't sign up for this
there was nothing in the offer letter
job description about this him
delivering well i mean obviously that
guy right there is definitely a believer
of doordash and what they do but what do
you think about the story here how much
you want to bet that guy went to an ivy
league school yeah
with you i actually absolutely love this
idea there's nothing worse than a
higher up corporate bureaucrat or
whatever you want to call it who's
completely out of touch
um i completely agree completely
you know there's to be a man of the
people to understand your product they
use the word specifically closer to our
audience this is exactly the purpose of
why they're actually doing this i assume
though tom so you understand what it's
like to deliver and be a driver and deal
with the traffic and deal with an angry
customer like
to put yourself in the average worker's
shoes how do this one guy who's making
400 grand is too cool for school to do a
delivery a month bro get a life
i completely agree and you know it's
interesting and the first uh company
that i got involved with pat he
he evangelized me into it and i thought
it was great and what i did and he knows
this
when i was in ubers
in an uber i would talk to the uber
driver and i would find out people that
were looking to do a little bit more
looking to do things and i recruited not
one not two but three that i passed off
to agents or at the company and i
thought uber drivers well yeah but but
the point is i ran into people and uber
happened to be the situation and i said
hey check out php look at the
opportunity you could have here if
you're looking for making a little extra
money this is a way to do it also
serving a market so i came to appreciate
at that moment
exactly what every one of our agent does
when they're when they were working with
that of course so i think this is good
to be out on the front i'm a product it
is jaime godina who worked at galpin
ford it's 2002. he sold me a ford focus
stayed up to 11 30 to sell me a ford
focus payment was 228 a month i was so
broke i lost my expedition i couldn't
pay the payments anymore i'm at the
lowest point of my life in o2
years later i said when i was sitting
with them he told me i said what what
what what car should i buy
he says well uh
what do you want to get i said what do
you have it's a great question let me
show you the cars that i have i have
this i have this i have this it was all
four products
i love the fact that a guy who owns the
product is selling it to me i i have a
hard time if you're selling mercedes
you're driving a bmw yeah like when uh
eli manning was doing the commercials
for toyota corolla and i was like get
out of here
there's a part of this that i like and
guess what this does the guy who's
running doordash just realized who
doesn't really believe in the concept of
what they do as a company and who's too
much of a high you know corporate
executive that's not going to get their
hands too dirty to go out there and say
you know what maybe this is what i got
to do to understand what everybody else
does it helps you get closer to your uh
to the folks that are also working my
question is who would think this is a
bad idea other than this engineer who
probably just wants to sit in front of a
computer all day maybe he's baked or not
cookies of course
why would
why is this a bad idea play devil's
advocate here this is not it's a bad
idea exactly i can't even think about it
by the way what i'm saying i can't even
think of it there are many companies
that do it already but i tell you i've
been in many meetings where you launched
an initiative and all of a sudden you
know
who's in and who's now right it's a
filtering process and i love the fact
that doordash announced this they push a
little harder it'll open up go a little
lower and push it hard it'll open up a
little lower there you go let me tell
you man that this actually annoys me so
much like i don't even want to use
doordash like this one guy being too
good for it but but don't let that
happen because the ceo's doing the right
i look at it the opposite way i actually
this is on my radar now it's like they
care about the customers i actually have
more respect for dash now totally i like
the fact that the ceo and the founder
thought about this idea so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you